we have new details tonight about the
clark county school district data breach
that's right brian we know that about 10
gigabytes
of information is on a website that is
not password protected
hackers recently posted those files
online including personal information of
students and staff
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us what is online
two cyber security companies confirmed
with me the upload by hackers
i also visited the group's website to
see it for myself
it's not on the dark web and some of the
documents there
go back years it's all open so anybody
who has internet access
or a browser could click on the link
access to stolen clark county school
district data
this is a very typical kind of what we
call the double extortion
gene ew is ceo of resecurity a cyber
company partnered with unlv for research
projects
he tells me the hackers likely got in
stole the data
disabled it from coming back unless ccsd
paid a ransom to unlock it
ccsd has not answered my questions about
whether it paid any money to the hackers
we can confirm that it's maze maze is
one that's doing the hack and leak
operation
the district first acknowledging the
breach last month
ccsd released another statement monday
it says in part
ccsd is working diligently to determine
the full nature
and scope of the incident and is
cooperating with law enforcement
but many parents seem concerned and are
posting online
obviously ccsd and all of us and our
children
are victims of a criminal attack
ccsd isn't necessarily the one who did
this
but the question then comes to what do
we do next
the files include names of employees and
social security numbers
as well as names and addresses of
students according to mcsoft
another cyber security company u advises
families and employees
to start credit monitoring kristen
drummond 8 news now
ccsd is not the only school district
impacted by ransomware
there have been 60 district and
universities attacks so far this year
the reason these attacks occur is
because they can be profitable and the
only way to stop it the experts say
is if organizations stop paying these
ransoms brian
the